[Applaudissements]
et bien bonjour comment allez vous moi
tout va extrêmement bien ses vacances
furent incroyablement ressources en eau
et surtout j'ai pris en maturité je vais
vous dire que cette année on va adopter
des thèmes un petit peu plus importants
des sujets un petit peu plus mature que
ce qu'on fait habituellement et cette
vidéo signera un nouveau départ écoutez
j'ai découvert un nouveau délai à un
monde dont je ne soupçonnais pas
l'existence le monde des ballons de
baudruche qu'est ce que c'est c'est ce
que font les clowns un anniversaire un
mariage à une fête foraine ses
sculptures en ballons là le petit chien
vous connaissez le petit chien écoutez
je savais pas mais il ya des chaînes
youtube de tuto pour apprendre à faire
des sculptures en ballon mais c'est le
paradis
dans ma tête c'était genre une
discipline qui était hyper secrète un
truc qui se transmettait de père clown
en fils klum rien d'autre j'ai les
fournitures scolaires dont nous avons
besoin
j'ai une pompe qui gauche et quand tu
pousses et quand tu tires trouver
quelqu'un plus fier de sa pompe que moi
ça n'existe pas on va suivre ces petites
ut hausse est beaucoup plus rapide et
simple que tout ce qu'on a fait jusqu'à
présent étonnamment je croyais que
c'était dur en fait pas du tout on va
commencer avec le petit chien on l'a
tous vu on nous en a tous offerts on
était tous très contents voilà
éliminions que je comprends toujours pas
en colère semble à un chien mais c'est
un chien jamais ma vie je pensais faire
un jour c'est incroyable
[Musique]
pourquoi comment c'est possible que le
premier truc le premier geste que je
fais du tuto et déjà ratée juste gonflé
ça ne marche pas ok super bien fait le
j'adore attends attends attends à l'ebu
ils sont horribles c'est hyper chiant
alors on va faire le 9-3 qui fait 1 me à
assaf images [ __ ] c'était longtemps je
partais ça ah ok le nom est fait ok là
ok oh ça me fait peur c'est bon tu m'as
fait part via d'escrimeur dans ce tuto
attend whaou mais c'est 10 de la magie
c'est plus un tuto avec des ballons et
comment il ya un truc est apparue j'ai
je n'ai rien compris
il a prêté ok j'ai la tête de mon cher
pourquoi ça ressemble à ça je sais pas
mais j'ai la tête de mon cher c'est pour
se venger le coup elle a juste un très
gros mais je n'ai aucun la suite à temps
c'est l'étape finale
attends je fais ça et après j'ai mon
chien le mec c'est en fait à chaque fois
commencé samedi un truc fallait être un
dieu oh ça fait un petit quelque chose
écoutez je vous assure jamais de ma vie
je me serais dit un jour je vais faire
un chien en ballon tout seul genre mon
propre chien en ballon mais je sais
qu'il y en a au fond parmi vous qui sont
dans une situation que moi j'en vous
saviez pas que c'était possible de faire
par ce même gène gioia que les pros qui
pouvait faire sa personne d'autres
genres nous nous on est on est le peuple
le plein on n'a pas accès à ça ça c'est
vraiment viiip c'est pas fini battus le
couple a que malte et c'est une cruauté
sans faille ouah mais pourquoi nous
manque une jambe à mon premier chien
j'ai rien fait j'étais en train de
regarder le tuto entendu au nom du coup
il perd son ventre en hypers sont bidons
je t'aimerai toujours mon pote avec ou
sans jambes je t'aimerai toujours pour
les amis on va tout de suite faire le
tuto qui m'a donné envie de faire cette
vidéo c'est extraordinaire et je pèse
mes mots mais rien ne passe
il est d'une sympathie c'est bien il l'a
il l'a fait avec sa bouche mais c'est un
monstre
[Musique]
mais c'est impossible
allez on prend la petite pompe tous les
loosers ah ok ok on fait deux petites
boules c'est bon j'ai fait mais ça
ressemble à rien on regarde et on dirait
comballot il a des tumeurs mais pourquoi
une parfaite et un gros tas genre
kanouté moi j'espère que ça n'empêchera
pas la suite arrête de faire ça à eux je
suis confluent des ballons tout petit
j'ai des points incroyables je progresse
j'arrive maintenant je n'ai rien compris
au moins une chute au dessin c'est clair
lech co prori ok attend là c'est la
partie où il fusionne les deux à temps
pour faire quoi ok j'ai jamais vraiment
donc là on voit il faut mettre salle à
la norme en mai la wii j'ai réussi à le
je suis vraiment content d'avoir un bel
arc je vais pas envoyer des ballons
baudruches avec monarque embargo gauche
texte est jalouse c'est non non non
pourquoi tu me laisse juste avec ça
qu'est ce que je fais moi j'ai fait une
épée voilà
[Musique]
telus est le deuxième pdc manon
tout va lâcher yes je m'en fous de ça
j'ai pas comme on le retire ce mot
refoulé ok pour retirer la partie qu'il
dépasse tu peux l'éclaté et ensuite tu
prends le ballon qui est mort et
pétulant roule autour d'autres choses je
me suis là est ce que c'est vraiment une
bonne idée
oh c'est bon c'est bon là on est en
train de sauver ça va aller je vais que
tu vas vivre voilà c'était moins une
mais le résultat est le même
les mecs mec je l'air ça marche mieux
bon c'est pas grave et des vidéos manuel
dans lesquelles on se sent mieux que
d'autres là je galère un peu mais j'ai
pas dit mon dernier mot il y a un truc
une nouvelle histoire sur moi voilà
c'est ces gens souvenir vague où je sais
plus où c'était j'ai plus avec qui
c'était je sais juste que j'étais très
petit soin que c'est avec l'école est un
endroit où il y avait un mec justement
qui faisait ça c'est son métier comme le
ghana vidéo c'était peut-être même le
mec de la vidéo mais j'oubliais son
visage est visé des panthères roses une
image manente d'une panthère emballement
douche ou alors dans mes souvenirs c'est
une panthère en fait c'est juste un
chien avec un ballon aux je sais pas
bref il avait fait ce jour-là pour
chacun un chapeau en ballons de
baudruche vous avez bien entendu et j'ai
trouvé le meilleur de tous les chapeaux
possible il s'appelle le chapeau fleurs
je suis un peu essoufflée j'ai un peu
perdu tout le mon courage mais qui sait
peut-être que c'est sur ce dernier tuto
qu'on va mieux s'en sortir sans doute
enfin me demandez pas pourquoi le
tutorat est vous ai dit c'est pas un
gros game sur youtube lequel dévalant
d'autres chiens je vais être franc avec
vous si vous vous lancez sur youtube
c'est peut-être pas
c'est pas ma faute celle d'ubs à
louvoyer bien moi je suis hyper non dans
ce que je suis en train de faire non
mais n'as tu pas trois de suite quoi bon
je te plaît ne va pas la suite parce que
c'est à dire hyper compliqué de faire ça
à temps il fait quoi mais ça mais mes
mecs tout ça explose pas quoi nemec il a
acheté ces ballons celle où il vit tout
mais ça va exploser je le sens dans mes
mains je le sens c'est évident que ça
explose quand tu appuies autant sur un
ballon guéant tangon flénu besoin d'être
un génie pour sa hausse allez on s'y
colle les mecs cette étape elle n'est
pas possible mais je vois pas comment
faire pour pas que ça explose je
comprends pas tant pis on va faire un
autre chapeau oublier la fleur
aujourd'hui ça va être l'amour
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je sais je sais c'est trop cool j'ai mon
chapeau et toi bon les amis j'en peux
plus je suis lavé nous lie c'est ce truc
d'être tendue que quelque chose arrive
comme ça et d'un coup il arrivait à sa
annuler les films et vacances la suite
en fait pour tout la vidéo j'ai eu peur
la canche et mes petits trucs le bal où
il explose et plusieurs fois il a
explosé donc j'avais encore plus peur
qu'il explose parce que je sais que ça
peut arriver chez tpe j'ai sous-estimé
cet art de la sculpture de ballons et en
vrai mec c'est super dur en tout cas la
prochaine fois que je vois un gars faire
des sculptures en ballon pour des
enfants et bien un mec je vais le
regarder comme ça
t'inquiète je connais bien franchement
toi moi je t'avais tellement réussie la
vérité c'est que tu avais tellement
réussis pas belle
[Applaudissements]
ça m'a fait du mal cette vidéo à bientôt
[Musique]